at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half-mile before my hands start
shaking discover this episode is brought
to you by peloton which I've been using
probably for about a year now peloton is
a cutting-edge indoor cycling bike that
brings live studio classes right into
your home you can also do on-demand
which is what I do we'll come back to
that so you don't have to worry about
fitting classes into a busy schedule or
making it to a studio or gym with a
hectic or unpredictable commute I for
instance have a peloton bike right in my
master bedroom at home and it's one of
the first things I do many mornings I
wake up I meditate for a bit then I
knock out a short 20 minute ride in my
undies hard to do that at the gym take a
shower and I'm in higher gear for the
rest of the day it's really convenient
and has become something that I look
forward to so you have a lot of options
for one if you like you can ride live
with thousands of other riders across
the country on an interactive
leaderboard to keep you motivated
there are also up to 14 new classes
added every day with more than 8,000
classes on demand and you can pick based
on length 45 minutes 20 minutes whatever
music hip hop rock and roll or say low
impact versus high intensity or interval
you can pick the class structure and
style that works for you and in my case
I quite liked Matt Wilbur's and I tend
to do on-demand and listen to a lot of
and watch many of the same classes over
and over but I'm kind of promiscuous and
also enjoy classes from a lot of the
other instructors they have peloton an
amazing roster of incredible instructors
in New York City with a whole range of
styles and personalities so you can find
what you're in the mood for you also get
real-time metrics that you can use to
track your performance over time and
that will help I would say catalyzed you
to beat your personal best now that all
sounds good right
gamification yadda yadda yadda I didn't
think that it would work for me or in
any way incentive ëismí but they really
100% hit the nail on the head I was very
very impressed with how motivating it
was
and it worked tremendously to keep me
pushing which quite honestly takes a
fair amount I can get quite lazy
particularly with anything that edges on
endurance which is kind of more than
five reps of anything for me so check it
out
discover this cutting edge indoor
cycling bike that brings a studio
experience right to your home peloton is
offering listeners of this podcast a
limited time offer go to one peloton
calm that's o-n-e peloton PE l oto and
calm and enter the code Tim all caps at
checkout and get $100 off of accessories
with your polish on bike purchase so get
a great workout at home anytime you want
check it out go to one peloton calm and
use the code Tim to get started this
episode is brought to you by
wordpress.com
I love WordPress I have used it for so
many years it's my go-to platform for
blogging and creating websites I use
wordpress.com for everything every day
my site Tim not blog is built on it
the websites for my books including
tools of titans tribe of mentors it's
all in wordpress.com and the founder
matt mullenweg when my close friends has
appeared on this show many times
just search Matt Mullenweg tequila
Ferriss for quite an exciting time
whether you're looking to create a
personal blog a business site or both
you can make a really big impact right
out of the box when you build on
wordpress.com and you'll be in good
company it's used by the New Yorker
jay-z Beyonce 538 TechCrunch Ted CNN and
time just to name a handful and one of
my friends at Google she'll remain
nameless has told me that wordpress.com
offers the quote best out-of-the-box
SEO imaginable end quote and it's one of
the many reasons that nearly 30 percent
of the Internet is run on WordPress you
do not need experience or to hire
someone that's perhaps the best part
wordpress.com guide you through the
entire experience they have hundreds of
designs and templates that you can use
and it's easy to get started there's no
need to worry about security upgrades
hosting any of that they offer 24/7
support and they're very very respond
if you've questions they can write back
to you and this allows you to create the
highest quality with the least amount of
headache and friction so if you're
building a website period when my
friends come to me and ask what I use
what I recommend they use the answer is
wordpress.com so check it out if you
want to get started today learn more
with a 15% discount off any new plan go
to wordpress.com forward slash Tim to
create your website and find the plan
that's right for you so learn more take
a look
wordpress.com forward slash Tim for a
15% off a brand new website check it out
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show this episode is not
going to be a long-form interview where
I distill and deconstruct world-class
performers in fact it is going to be
nothing of the sort
it is a QA episode this is tea time with
Tim or Timmy or Timbo if you prefer
where I solicited phone numbers from all
of you and called a handful of you to
field any questions that you might have
and I've done these before there are
always a lot of fun for me to do and
among other topics covered in the
various phone calls that you will hear
in this episode how to find mentors how
do I think about finding mentors how
have I found mentors in the past
discussions of meaning Viktor Frankl and
so on how to get rid of anxiety or train
into confidence we talked about that as
it relates to a handful of things
cocktails
relationship advice if we go all over
the place and I hope you enjoy this as
much as I enjoyed recording it so
without further ado here is tea time
with Tim
hello is this Edwin
yes it is Edwin this is Tim Farriss
calling good afternoon
hey Tim how you doing oh man I can't I
can't believe this is real
yeah it's real I'm afraid if I have you
I have here well me too okay me too so
let's jump right into it
how can I help any and I can't promise I
can help but I'll try to answer whatever
questions you might have
I appreciate that so my question is
about mentors so what guidance do you
have for finding a mentor to kind of
help maybe gain a better understanding
about an industry and I think more
importantly how would you or what
guidance you have for asking someone to
be a mentor how do you approach them how
do you kind of break that or make that
initial contact mm-hmm
I can I can actually answer this one so
the the first rule of thumb is that I
would HIGHLY advise against ever asking
someone directly to be a mentor in using
those words because the people you
generally will want as a mentor unless
they're retired are probably quite busy
and will hear mentor is unpaid part-time
or a full-time job before ever
and therefore you want to approach it
somewhat indirectly and there are a few
different ways to do that there's also a
resource I can recommend which is a book
a call to the third door which I think
does a very good job of exploring real
life case studies of communication that
works in communication that doesn't work
when you're reaching out to people who
are where you'd like to be or who could
be possible mentors even remotely by
what they write and so on
so I would suggest checking out that
page you know I'm actually I have it in
my hand I heard your interview with Alex
vinayan on your podcast and man I have
to say I am a fan it got me through some
hard times and that's where I initially
came across this book and I'm I'm right
around that chapter I may be like 60 70
pages in and I just read the part where
kind of goes into the intro how we kind
of talk to you and so I think that's
where that question came for
Oh perfect great I just yeah so I'm just
trying to break into this and I'm trying
to kind of not repeat those mistakes
that he highlights and you know yeah so
let me let me let me take a stab at the
saving you from some pitfalls the the
way that I first connected with people
who later became mentors in a sense when
I landed in Silicon Valley in 2000 was
through volunteering so I highly
recommend volunteering and the reason
for that is that many organizations
including entrepreneurial or
entrepreneurship focused organizations
that could be the EO the entrepreneurs
organization it could be young
presidents organization YPO it could be
any number of others there are many of
them in Silicon Valley I volunteered at
ty which is the Indus entrepreneur even
though I'm clearly not Indian and
volunteered at s vase which at the time
was the Silicon Valley associate
association of startup entrepreneurs and
they given their location and given
their focus were able to get media to
attend to cover speakers meaning to
feature speakers in articles and so on
for Forbes or fortune whatever might be
and that meant if I were to volunteer
even if I were simply taking tickets or
refilling water glasses both of which I
did I would have an opportunity if I
over performed which is easy in fact in
most volunteer capacities because the
people who show up very often have the
attitude I'm not getting paid for this
so I will do the bare minimum that they
ask of me
so if you are proactive and asking for
additional responsibility or is there
anything else I can help with I finished
X can I help with anything else if you
are proactive and really responsible and
get things done on time you'll very
often find that they will be more than
happy to give you additional
responsibility and that is how I ended
up ultimately sitting in on planning
meetings and volunteering to act as a
speaker liaison
or an event which allowed me to reach
out to people I wanted to get to know
like Jack Canfield who is the co-creator
is the co-creator of Chicken Soup for
the Soul which has sold hundreds of
millions of copies the person who
commercialized creatine first creatine
monohydrate that is the creator of the
pet rock I had a very motley crowd of
folks I wanted to assemble and there had
to be something in it for them and what
was in it for them was speaking in front
of an audience of entrepreneurs with
media in attendance to cover them so I
was not asking them for any favors in
fact I was asking them if they'd be
willing to sort of a receive media
coverage in effect and also interact
with other people at their level and it
was it was during that event I wanted to
do one thing and it was not asked them
if they could be a mentor it was to
demonstrate to them that I was very very
good at doing my job so I wanted it to
be the smoothest speaking experience
I've ever had I wanted it to be an event
to remember I wanted to ensure that they
had the media contacts they wanted to
have interactions that is and following
that event I later much later maybe a
month or two later reached out after
thanking the speakers each speaker
separately and as a group to say King I
think it was Jack Canfield at the time
and I used an approach that was similar
to what I outlined in the 4-hour
workweek when reaching out to experts
who are above your paygrade
and in effect said you know Jack I
really enjoyed our interactions I hope
we get to meet again and if it's okay
with you I'd love to very rarely but if
the occasion calls for it send you a
question that overlaps with your deep
experience if I'm totally stuck after
trying to figure something out and it
was along those lines and Jack then
I kept in touch with now it's important
for me to qualify what that means keep
in touch with does not mean pester it
does not sit it does not mean send him
quarterly updates it does not mean a
clog his inbox it means that maybe once
every six to twelve months I would send
him a legitimate question and I would
indicate what I'd already tried to do to
answer the question this is really
important so if you reach out to a
potential mentor or someone who has more
life experience and you say hi Tim I was
just wondering I'm studying this in
school what should I do
that's a terrible question because it
doesn't reflect if you've actually tried
to figure it out on your own or if
you're using me for your personal Google
it also does not lend itself to a
specific answer so you have to ask
yourself is this a question that this
person could answer in four lines or
less and if you're if you look at the
question and realize it's going to take
them a half-hour to answer it because
you're asking them for the meaning of
life and to explain their trajectory and
how they grew their career then it's a
bad question because you have more time
than they do and you should be aware of
that from the outset so generally be a
question like you know the the question
I'd love to ask you does X here the
things I've already tried my tentative
plan is this if you have any other
thoughts I would really appreciate them
and if you're too busy to respond I
totally understand so give them an out
so that they feel comfortable not
responding and completely unprecedent
and and perhaps counter-intuitively
that'll get you more answers because
what many younger go-getters will do is
they'll send an email and they'll finish
it with looking forward to your reply or
I have Tuesday at 2:00 p.m. and Thursday
at 1:00 p.m. central open which one
works for you and it's so presumptive
yeah and aggressive yeah that the no
matter what the content of that email
the person receiving it will be likely
to think to themselves well [ __ ] if I if
I reward this person with a response to
this email
I am encouraging them to send me 20 more
of these emails and I don't want to do
that so I'm not going to respond so
that's that's one one approach and I
would also encourage you to look for a
South by Southwest talk that I gave
which funny enough coincides with South
by Southwest starting right now today
and tomorrow in Austin Texas in early
March but the talk is titled
how to build a world-class network in
record time or something equally
hyperbolic in any case it is though an
accurate reflection of the talk and you
may be able to find out on the podcast
so there's a chance that I took the
audio and put it on the on the podcast
but if you if you google how to build a
world-class network in record time and
Tim Ferriss something will pop up
whether it is a video recording of the
presentation at South by or it is audio
on the podcast itself which I do think I
had repurposed the audio for so those
are my thoughts if you're reading the
third door I think that will also
complement a lot of what we're talking
about so I hope that helps does that
fill in some gaps hopefully or give you
some direction yes definitely and I mean
I must say it's one thing they're
reading in a book or to hear it on your
podcast but kind of to hear it straight
from you which just adds a little more
weight to it and it definitely just
makes it sound doable so I really
appreciate it and I think you for your
time and I just you know you're you're
so definitely has been a game changer
for me so thank you for that and keep
doing what you're doing and I really
appreciate it but thank you so much
thanks so much my pleasure of course and
I should point out one other thing which
is when I mentioned Jack Canfield for
instance I said it once every six to
twelve months that's a long time so that
that as an indicator that I'm playing
the long game right the question you
shouldn't be asking and I don't think
you are but the question you shouldn't
be asking is how can I find a mentor for
the next 12 months
if you're looking for something like
that it's going to end up being somewhat
transactional and you're going to have
to force something within a context of a
group like the entrepreneurs
organization where people are going
there explicitly for that purpose to
learn from one another to teach to and
so on otherwise I would encourage you to
reframe the question in your head so the
question isn't how do I get a mentor the
question is how can I encourage people I
aspire to be like who are 10 20 30 years
ahead of me to respect me and want me to
succeed that's a better question how do
I get people say 5 10 20 years ahead of
me whose paths I might want to emulate
how do I get those people to respect me
and want me to succeed and if you do
that that's a precursor to them helping
you in ways that resemble those of a
mentor but the word mentor is probably a
word that will never come up even though
in practice that's what they will be
doing for you does that make sense yes
it does and I think that it's one of
those that Tim Ferriss hidden gems and I
think that's the exact answer I was
hoping for that's the exact type of
answer I was hoping for in it yeah I
think you answered it perfectly so just
let last question here's to what do you
think about the handwritten follow-up
note sometimes they say you know emails
are better sometimes they say you know
handwritten you know thank-you notes for
even just you know asking these
questions via you know a handwritten
letter or what have you do you have any
thoughts on if one is better than the
other I don't think a handwritten letter
is necessary and a lot of people myself
included do not want to give out their
mailing addresses even if it's a P o box
so I would say it's it's unnecessary
giving someone a handwritten note at an
event is a different story and I do
recommend to that but you can listen to
the talk that I gave on that topic at
South by Southwest and on the podcast
which I mentioned earlier and that will
get into details on that
all right my man I will leave you to it
good luck and nice chatting with you
thank you you have a great day
all right buh-bye Steve this is Tim
Ferriss calling good afternoon
oh my gosh how are you doing I'm doing
great I am doing fantastic it's a
beautiful day and I am excited to
attempt to answer any question you might
have so I am happy to let you take it
from here well this is amazing and I'm
so excited to talk to you though I can't
two different questions I didn't know if
you wanted more of a kind of meaning of
life question or if you prefer like a
like a job kind of question I would say
pick if if you could only get one of
them answered pick that one because that
may be the case because I want to make
sure that I am able to call more than a
few people so I would say pick pick the
one you would most like to have answered
if you had to choose one and then if it
goes quickly then we can consider a
second one but we'll try one okay great
um well
so recently guys I've read him search
for meaning and that it was just a great
book and it really made a big impact on
me and made me think a lot about purpose
and finding meaning in life and I guess
my question for you is you've reached
such a high level of success being able
to affect so many people and so I guess
my question for you is once you've
reached that level how do you continue
to find purpose in your life has it
evolved you know what would you say your
purpose is right now this is a good
question big question as well I would
say that I'll try to tackle that in a
somewhat meandering fashion so the the
first thing I would say is my approach
to book writing my approach to the
podcast
my approach to
the television shows I've been involved
with has had a common thread that is
very very simple people might even
consider it simplistic and that is if I
have a pain or a problem or if I have a
desire or goal I assume it is very
likely that many other people have the
same pains or problems or desires or
goals so most of what I do is scratching
my own itch with the expectation that if
I can figure out how to how to navigate
any of those things well and take good
notes and test a lot so that I can try
the hundred things to filter down to the
one or two that truly have a
disproportionate disproportionately good
outcome that that is a straightforward
way of adding value to the world and not
just consuming oxygen and eating
resources so that's that is my general
process which is a way of backing into
your question about you know what what
is giving me meaning right now what is
giving me meaning right now is looking
at some of the traumatic experiences I
had as a child
looking at the repercussions of that and
the behaviors or thought patterns that
are impossible to explain that I still
have in some cases without looking in
the rearview mirror and somehow
metabolizing or integrating what
happened to me that never had a sense of
closure and that then ties into a lot of
the research I'm supporting related to
treatment resistant depression related
to long term demoralisation in say AIDS
survivors at UCSF and a lot of what I'm
hoping to do with universities and other
groups including Johns Hopkins at the
top of the list and for me
then it's it's it's assuming that right
now for me that everyone is fighting
battles we know nothing about like
literally everyone there is some degree
of suffering whether it's minor or major
chronic or acute that everyone walking
around you see I mean I'm looking out a
high-rise right now down at the ground
so I see these hundreds of ants which
will soon be thousands and tens of
thousands with South by Southwest and
assuming that every one of those people
has some type of suffering past or
present tense that is affecting how they
make decisions how they interact how
they view themselves and if I can
provide any tools whatsoever to decrease
that suffering and to allow them to help
other people who are suffering then I
view that as time very very well spent
so that's how I'm thinking about it
right now but I'm not wedded to that and
I think it can fluctuate I do think the
filling the void chapter in the 4-hour
workweek which is probably the most
neglected yet most important chapter in
some respects in the entire book towards
the tail-end ties into a lot of the
observations that you would read in
Victor Frankel's book and books for that
matter and so there are certainly
complimentary chapters and books that
you could digest but when in doubt I
would say instead of trying to save the
world look at how you can save yourself
or help yourself in some fashion and by
doing something that seems very selfish
on the surface you're actually being
very practical because you are
scratching your own itch in such a
fashion that you're not purely
speculating you are dealing with the
real world even if it is limited to you
which I can pretty much guarantee if
it's any type of suffering if it's any
type of desire there's a very very high
likely
probably a hundred percent but let's
just call it very high likelihood that
there are thousands at a minimum and
probably millions of people in the world
with some close cousin of that if not
the exact same thing in their daily
experience so that's that's how I
currently am and thinking about it but I
should also say that there's no there's
no one right answer here and so that
your meaning could be playing music and
brightening people's days for sixty
minutes or thirty minutes when you get
on stage to play your set because you've
carefully crafted this art to change the
emotional state of people who are
sitting within 50 feet of you that and
if that gave you meaning and certainly I
think that's I think that is meaningful
I think that's very meaningful even
though other people who might sit on the
sidelines and judge which is usually the
people who judge by the way it's not the
people in the arena who are actually
scraping their knees and getting things
done but the peanut gallery on the
internet and on the side criticizing you
saying that you should be spending your
time a different way there is no should
this is that we're not dealing with you
know the natural laws or physical you
know hard scientific laws that are sort
of in I mean we can get into a
conversation of objectivity but let's
just call them objective truths for for
the sake of this thought exercise we're
dealing with your perception of what
matters and your perception of what
matters I think though you should listen
to other people and I encourage you to
to talk to other people about how they
think about it your perception of what
matters is your perception of what
matters and you can own that and you can
consider a valid I would say that it's
helpful as you're walking around in the
world as a perceiving machine to perhaps
read or listen to certain books like
awareness
by Anthony de Mello would be a one
recommendation that I would have but
I'll stop talking in a second because
this is a long answer but I can't give
the meaning of life but I can tell you
where I think my most leveraged point of
focuses for creating meaning as I feel
it today and it's not a purely cognitive
exercise I should say it's not that I
think about it and sit down with a
spreadsheet although with some of the
investments and donations I make in
science I do think about the downstream
effects of certain landmark studies for
instance so I do use an analytical side
to it but the the analytical is more in
my case these days for the execution so
I really try to feel with what what do I
get a whole body yes - that makes me and
other people feel better or that in some
fashion solves a problem or helps me or
others to get what they're hoping to
have or it gives people hope then
enables them in some fashion you know
what what is the feeling that I want
right so instead of saying how do I find
meaning say like what is the feeling I
hope to have when I find meaning we're
sort of an antecedent or if you can kind
of diagnose what you need by looking at
the the symptoms the side effects which
would be how you would feel like if you
were doing something really meaningful
what would that give you that you don't
currently have and then try to map that
as you're talking about different ideas
different topics different ways you
could spend your time like when does
that feel and come up and then if you
use that as one criterion for deciding
where you might want to focus to create
meaning then you can use the analytical
to build a plan for executing on
everything we just described but that's
long answer - sure
question hopefully that wasn't
completely word salad did any of that
make any sense whatsoever that was
incredible and and thank you so much I
that's extremely helpful in in my
situation and I just really appreciate
you you know taking the time to answer
my question and that's super helpful
thank you Tim and and I just feel like I
need to say thank you for everything
that you that you do and that you've
done I know you hear this all the time
but you know I've been following your
work for a very very long time and you
know it's you've made so many impacts on
my own life and I know you've made
impacts on so many people so I just want
to say thank you for for being you and I
really really appreciate you thank you
Steve I appreciate you as well
honestly it's like I wouldn't be here
able to do this if I didn't have
listeners and readers who've been so
incredibly supportive of this accidental
career I've ended up having so it's a
real blessing to be able to do this in
any way and it means a lot that you
would even fill out the form to allow me
to call so it's of course my pleasure in
it and I should emphasize too I'm still
figuring this out I'm still making it up
as I go along and testing and at the end
of the day for me whether it's looking
for meaning or trying to create meaning
which I think are two different
approaches that can be very
complimentary trying to figure out early
stage investing or any number of dozens
of other things I might get my hands
into rather than trying to debate in
your own head or with other people what
the best approach might be what the best
next step might be out of say three or
four or even more things I just try to
test them so I look for low-cost tests
with limited downside that I can throw
out into the world to see what happens
to see what sticks and what doesn't so
that's all I'm doing
and uncertainly learn
from lots and lots of people around me
including people like yourself so I'll
let you I'll let you get back to your
day but thanks very much for taking the
time yourself thank you so much Tim I
really appreciate it all right man take
it easy
bye hello every speaking hello Heather
speaking this is Tim Ferriss speaking
good day no it's not it is
why hello house house has the other the
weather
I said Heather how's the Heather I guess
opposed we could speak that way as well
how's the Heather and how is the weather
surrounding Heather at the moment that's
how kids get to learn my name
remember it rhymes indeed I was going to
say looked like you were calling or I
should say I was calling a Toronto
number fine City it is some fantastic
friends and fantastic startups also in
that lovely city of yours that does get
a little chilly what might I be able to
attempt to answer for you Heather
so I'm a late bloomer and I am I have
started taking karate I've been invited
to take my uh nervous black belt test in
the spring congratulations and God thank
you but I'm so nervous just like I don't
know and I'm a bit of a choker take your
time there's no rush I'm not going
anywhere I'm just sitting here with my
tea in a computer thank you so I I know
that you do all kinds of these and I'm
just wondering what your method is for
staying focused and calm so that the
short answer is that I'd like to
simulate the test environment as much as
possible beforehand that can include
many different factors so for instance
if I'm gonna be speaking on stage
somewhere whether that's Ted or a
different venue I will go I will always
make sure that
a chance ideally the day before maybe
the day of to go spend time on the stage
and to test all the technical equipment
and to know exactly where I'm gonna have
breakfast the next day if it's a large
conference that I don't have to worry
about there being any hiccup in
logistics right so I would map out the
entire day that you anticipate or
versions of the day that you anticipate
on your test day and look at all of the
things that could stress you out
potentially look at all the things in
the night before that could stress you
out or cause issues and then do two
things number one is try to set up a
system so that you run into the fewest
number of those things as possible and
then secondly practice the screw ups
beforehand so that if they do happen you
aren't going to be as reactive and
thrown off if that makes sense right so
so that could include going to and using
visualization is fine for a lot of this
but let's just say that there's a
possibility I'm making up this example
right but if there's a possibility that
yeah at a specific speaking location of
do a lot of speaking anymore but let's
just say hypothetically I'm gonna go on
and get a coffee and I think the coffee
the coffee shop might be completely
overrun with people and I don't like
crowds even though I can speak in front
of crowds I don't actually like being in
crowds so two things number one I'm
gonna come up with contingency plans
right so maybe I buy my own coffee
machine at Target that I can replace so
her return two days later
maybe I get some instant coffee from
Starbucks maybe I decide to use room
service and a half backup plants that I
don't have to do that and then I could
also go in a number of times when it's
really really busy and visualize that it
is the day of my speaking gig or
the black belt test and practice calming
yourself down I think part of part of
the mistakes or one of the mistakes
excuse me that that folks make is they
practice skills like meditation and
mindfulness in a vacuum if that makes
sense so that's exactly right so they
will meditate in the morning when it's
completely quiet before anyone's gotten
up on their special cushion in their
special room and then they go to the DMV
and they completely lose their [ __ ]
because they haven't practiced the skill
in the environment that most demands it
or the type of environments so for
instance a few years ago I went on my
first well it was not my first caribou
hunt in this case was an elk hunt I
don't I don't hunt very much consume
everything that I hunt but I do hunt
occasionally and I won an elk hunt did
not end up harvesting any elk but in
preparation for that because it was
going to be a bow hunt
I was practicing in upstate New York
with archery and I hired a coach I was
doing all sorts of technical training
which you've done already for your black
belt test right you've done the
technical practice it's doing technical
practice but then I realized a few
things when I travel in this case to
Colorado I'm gonna be going from sea
level to something like between seven
and eleven thousand feet of elevation so
my heart is automatically going to be
beating a lot faster just to make to
oxygenate my blood properly or oxygenate
my tissues I suppose more effectively
second I am almost certainly going to be
extremely nervous
at that point had never even seen a bull
elk and they're gigantic
they're like horse with these enormous
antlers and they make these really
incredible shrieking sounds sounds like
a woman like being thrown off a cliff or
something they make these incredible
sounds so I assumed if I run into an L
which is the objective and I have a a
whatever the draw is on the bow pulled
back and my muscles are super tense and
I've been wondering if I'll screw it up
all day long I'm probably going to feel
like I've had you know three double
espressos okay if if that's the case I
should practice under those
physiological conditions so what I did
is I did a number of things I would do
say 20 or 30 burpees or 40 or 50
kettlebell swings and then I would pick
up the bow and take one shot and I did
this when I was practicing in New York
because I wanted to get my heart rate
well over say like 180 so I do whatever
necessary to get very physiologically
but I would consider off baseline and
then to attempt the skill right and you
want to be safe with this of course but
I would mimic that and I also did that
when I was preparing for my TED talk I
would I would down a bunch of double
espressos and then go in to give the
presentation because I'm giving a
presentation as a rehearsal in front of
a familiar crowd ultimately when I'm
blinded by the house lights or the stage
lights rather and unable to see people
in the crowd my body is going to react
very differently so I want to mimic that
how far out is your black belt test
right now they haven't set the date but
I think valuations in May okay so you
have you have something like two months
so do you do do you do any type of
performance in front of crowds do you
have you done any public speaking or
sports competitions things of that
nature in the past many moons ago I
perform in front of people it's been a
few decades so they just find that I'm
four well the idea yeah what is what is
what is the format of the black belt
test is it going to be the class
watching you is it going to be
in a familiar location a new location
what does it look like I from what I
understand there are two main testing
locations and there's sort of more of a
formality gathering but none of them are
in in locations that I typically that I
would get to practice that on the nor
like they're not at the dojo mm-hmm and
I think they're far out and big vary
quite a number what what are what are
your concerns what are you worried could
happen I'm blank
hmm there was a time where I was in a
another competition and when it when it
came game day I just got so nervous I
couldn't find my feet with nothing to do
with martial arts but still in so I have
that fear that it's going to happen
again and it's ridiculous no it's not
ridiculous I don't think it's ridiculous
at all I really don't think it's
ridiculous it's it's a response that
your body and psyche are having to a
past experience to protect you right so
you're so subconsciously you're trying
to protect yourself to prevent what
happened from happening again
that makes perfect sense so that the way
you overcome that is in my experience
not by expecting that on game day you're
gonna be able to summon the self-talk
that is going to be a hundred times more
effective than any of your self-talk in
the past it's by rehearsing what you
fear so you have two months which is
great news so I would think about other
things that make you nervous that would
make you specifically nervous about
blanking right whether that's getting up
on stage and talking in front of people
if that's an example then find a local
Toastmasters for instance and get up on
stage and start doing that because
you'll you will then be begin to develop
more confidence in your ability to
either not blank or to blank and recover
from blanking does that make sense
so I I would look for other
circumstances that would provoke the
same fear and practices as much as
possible I would also find out ahead of
time what the locations are and I would
spend time at those locations because
the fewer new variables you can have on
the day of testing the better off you'll
be
I would never for instance when I was
competing a thousand years ago I would
never ever set foot into a competitive
arena or on a mat or anything like that
for the first time when I was about to
compete or do some type of testing I
would always do recon ahead of time and
I would not I would know where the
bathrooms are I would know where the
main entrance is I would know I would
have an idea of what the process is
going to be for instance when I did my
black belt test at the Codel Con in
Tokyo in Japan when I lived there from
15 to 16 for its when I was in Japan I
was part of the Judo Club which is the
judo team I mean judo boot really but
the doesn't translate particularly well
into English but judo team and that's
where we did our black belt test so I
did recon even then to know exactly what
the process would look like what the
format would look like and to actually
attend a few practices in that facility
just so that I would have a familiarity
with say the temperature of the mats
right which is which it can vary
tremendously in judo from location to
location I'm sure for other things as
well but the kind of plastic rubbery
tatami mats that they use in judo could
be freezing cold in one place and really
really warm in another which affects the
hardness or the relative hardness or
softness right so all of these things I
would want to be exposed to before it
matters before it counts hey there's
also a very good book I can recommend
that has helped me a lot I've read it
over and over again it has a rather
cheesy title but the content
is exceptional and very very practical
it's by Dale Carnegie and it's called
how to stop worrying and start living
and may seem like a dramatic
recommendation for this particular
example that you've brought up but the
fear of blanking and how that can be
self reinforcing if that makes sense
right like the fear of blanking makes it
more likely that you are going to blink
so that is a psychological it's it's a
question of psychology and mindset as
well as skillset and this is I think the
neglected component that I've been
alluding to since I started rambling in
response to this is that if someone asks
me and I do get asked this pretty
frequently like how do I build my
confidence like what should my self-talk
look like how can I develop confidence
and my answer is you don't develop it in
the vacuum you develop confidence by
systematically exposing yourself to
discomfort and things that you think are
just outside of your capabilities are
just outside of your comfort zone and as
you do that you can you condition
yourself to better tolerate stress and
to take what you previously would have
considered risks even though now you
recognize them as very achievable
trainable objectives and that's how you
build confidence you build confidence by
doing these things because at the end of
the day like your inner critic your
inner voice is going to know the truth
right you can do all you can listen to
all of the motivational audio that you
want but if you even if you haven't put
in the work and you haven't set foot in
this arena if you haven't subjected
yourself to similar situations that
would provoke this fear of blanking you
are going to know on a deep level on the
flip side this is the good news if
you've done those things you show up and
you know you've done everything you
could have done and the self-talk is
I've done all of the preparation like I
have prepared more methodically than
anyone else who is taking this test and
therefore all I need to do now is simply
let come out what I've been technically
practicing for X number of months X
number of years all right like I have I
have turned over every stone I could to
prepare for this and that is what makes
it far less likely that you're gonna
blank or I should say End gives you the
confidence that if you blank which has
happened to me dozens of times on stage
in front of big audiences while I'm
speaking like literally like just poof
gone do not know what the hell comes
next and once you've learned kind of how
to tap dance with that you you develop
confidence not just your in your ability
to execute on a plan but your ability to
improvise and those would be those would
be some some of my thoughts but really
it's remove as many unknowns as possible
if you have what if this what if that go
practice that go practice that what if
in some capacity and you know maybe
that's asking to go to a different
karate school with people you don't know
to participate in a class or to do a
demo like would you mind and you could
explain to the teacher like I'm not
coming in here with a lot of swagger I'm
trying to prepare for my black belt test
I'm really nervous I'm gonna blank I'm
working with my teacher but one thing
that was recommended to me is getting
into unfamiliar environments because
that's what the testing environment is
going to be to actually perform so that
I have less fear of blanking when it
matters and I'm sure that you could find
you could even ask your instructor if
there's another instructor he or she can
recommend who would be open to hosting
you in a way right so there there are
ways to practice this stuff that's a
great idea yeah so that's which which
was taught to me right this is all stuff
that I picked up from other people who
are really really seasoned competitors
in them in most instances
I am not that yeah yeah yeah so this is
this these are just bits and pieces that
I've picked up over time for inoculating
yourself against sort of a nebulous fear
and there's there's another exercise
that I would very very strongly
recommend you go through because you may
realize look even if I blank and this
doesn't work doesn't happen
I can retest three months later or six
months later right and and there's a
thought exercise that you can go through
which involves some writing so I guess
it's more than just a thought exercise
called fear setting which if if you
haven't if you haven't seen it or even
if you have it may be an opportune time
to revisit this is something I do very
regularly probably at least once a
quarter maybe even once a month and you
can find that at tim dot blog forward
slash ted since i also discussed the
process in time to a point where I think
it's called with other people yeah I
would I would go and you know print out
that blog post and just run through the
exercise even if it seems in some way
academic I think that it will also
alleviate a lot of unnecessary pressure
or fear that you're probably imposing on
yourself that may not be extremely well
defined and to that book how to stop
worrying and start living will also chip
away at that with different tools and
recommendations that was Dale Carnegie
that's right mm-hmm okay okay thank you
a one small question I hear rigorous
more so than our regular training and I
don't know if I should
leading up with I have more a rest time
or more like go at it and the giver
leading up to it to practice what do you
what do you recommend I just I'm not
athletics is not my my background so my
tell it necessarily and I'm looking to
get through it and and tried to do so is
great
we as I can but I hear that it's quite a
long today and by design it's exciting
yeah I would I would rest quite a bit in
the week before the actual test
particularly in the few days beforehand
but but since you have two months I
would strive to make your training
harder than the test day right by design
right and if you've gone through things
that are harder than the actual fight so
to speak
you will come in with a very very well
earned high level of confidence that you
are physically capable because you've
already stress tested those
circumstances so I would I would
absolutely you know within safe
boundaries of course make your training
harder than your competition slash
certification for sure 100% and I think
is our key locus one of my favorite
quotes is we do not rise the level of
our expectations we fall to the level of
our training Frank so hope and since I'm
high on tea right now and want to use
courts I'll also say you know there's
there's a longer quote by James Cameron
the the director Terminator avatar etc
Titanic which begins with hope is not a
strategy
hope is not a sighted hope is not a
strategy so I conditioned yourself by
making your training at least at a few
points beforehand physically more
demanding than the test day and figure
out ways to do that and it doesn't
necessarily have to be karate but it
should be something that is physically
more demanding than the test day I would
simulate it as closely as humanly
possible okay thank you very much you're
welcome to consider getting a trainer
yeah you should
so that's the best of luck with your
with your black belt test very exciting
yeah congratulations my day you too
buh-bye Justin Justin how is it in
California or at least on a California
telephone this is Tim Ferriss Tim
Ferriss you know I was expecting your
call
well here I am not not not to not to
leave you hanging
I appreciate that everything's great I'm
down here in Los Angeles how's house
Austin Texas presumably treating you
it's fantastic he decided to brighten up
and offer the Sun just as people are
arriving for South by Southwest which it
always does
to seduce everyone but the weather is
actually generally very nice but it's
been cold for the last week or so how
can I be of assistance what question
might I be able to answer or attempt to
answer well you know this is more of a
personal question and I read the blurb
and I said what's an interesting
question that I could ask him Ferriss
because he is generally in charge of
interesting questions and I thought if
Tim Tim if you had to identify as a type
of cocktail what would that cocktail be
and why would you identify as it I had
to be a cocktail you know the first
thing that came to mind was an old
fashioned just because I feel like for
me there should be certain constants in
life you should have for instance
consistency with values and how you make
decisions with your values as an
operating system effectively for the go
no-go decisions do not do spend time
with this person versus avoid this
person type of decisions on the other
hand past the basic ingredients with say
an old fashioned you then have as a as a
bartender quite a bit of room to
improvise and add your own Flair
and it can vary tremendously from from
place to place so I think that then
offers the flexibility to reinvent
yourself with respect to projects with
respect to career with respect to how
you manifest those values in priorities
that guide you day to day on a more
operational a more operational level so
that is the first thing that comes to
mind when you ask about cocktail there's
like some some consistency and a bedrock
foundation that you can rely on and
expect and then you have the room to
improvise and be creative and reinvent
as needed with all sorts of other types
of adornments and highlights subtle or
over-the-top as you see fit that was a
fantastic answer that exceeded all my
expectations glad you liked it and that
was a pretty quick one is there as a
give any other questions or would you
like to leave it at the cocktail I'm
sure you know since have you I don't
know I will be able to get you on a
phone call is I'm 27 years old I'm a
gentleman I consider myself I'm
constantly trying to learn and you know
I'm a huge fan of the podcast and I
can't express my gratitude enough for
everything that you do for myself and
everybody else I'm somebody that
generally struggles with finding you
know my purpose and I don't want to go
square peg round hole as far as trying
to force myself down a walk of life that
you know maybe isn't exactly fit for me
was there a time that you felt that you
were particularly stagnant and maybe you
weren't fitting in where you thought you
should have been was just something that
maybe helped you get over that I've had
that feeling at many points in my life
so the first thing I would say is that
it is a normal experience and in fact at
your exact age I was having that feeling
27 I would have been in the process of
travelling trying to figure out what I
was going to do next so I would have
been bouncing from place to place living
on the cheap whether it was Ireland or
Berlin or any number of other places
wondering what the hell am I going to do
with my life so I was at the exact same
point in some respects that you are it
sounds like from what you're describing
it's the first thing I would say is
don't panic don't don't view it as a
personal flaw a defect don't don't think
that you are somehow uniquely unfocused
and that the universe of 27 year olds
outside of yourself has this figured out
because that's generally not the case
and I've had that feeling at multiple
points and I expect it to come up and I
I don't dread it because I've learned to
view it as an indicator that something
is not working right there is something
that I need or something that I want or
something that I want to give to others
or to the world that is is not being
accomplished right now so try to view it
as a simple indicator to zoom out to
30,000 feet and in try to reassess where
things are in terms of what you do after
reassessing and one way to reassess by
the way is to get a book like the 8020
principle and the last name it's Richard
Koch it may actually be pronounced [ __ ]
I have no idea
Koh I never know how to pronounce it I'm
gonna go with coke the 80/20 principle
the 8020 way I think living the 80/20
way there are a number of books that he
has written which focus exclusively on
the 80/20 principle which I view is very
helpful from a diagnostic perspective if
you're just looking at first
establishing a baseline right where are
you expending
energy where are you allocating your
time what are the results that are
coming from the various categories of
activities and what type of emotional
payoff are you getting or not getting
from those things
what are the things you want to get rid
of it's another way to from a sideways
angle get to what you want is to also
identify what you what you would like to
subtract what are the things you're
doing the people you're spending time
with the things you're committing to etc
that you would like to remove that are
causing negative stress as opposed to
positive adaptive stress in your life
so I would suggest those books or one of
them for diagnostic purposes and then
after that the natural question that
comes up is well what then what what do
you do
hopefully through that assessment
process you'll have some indication of
tests that you can run and I say tests
or experiments because it is a very low
pressure labeling to use you're not at
27 making a decision for the rest of
your life right and it's important to
frame it that way because if you view a
decision as a 5 or 10 year commitment
and there are paths where that is for
that that can be the case saying
medicine but outside of a handful of
areas you can look at in even in the
case of medicine there are experiments
that you could run so for instance would
it be possible if you were considering
traveling in a medical path and thought
that might be something you'd want to
pursue that you could sit in at a
medical school and audit a class and ask
a professor who has a great reputation
among students and that's easy to figure
out with online course rankings and so
on or whose one specific teaching awards
could you sit in an auditor class
because you are considering pursuing
medical school and a career in medicine
is that something that you could use as
an experiment for two weeks to sit in on
these classes
to give you more information and to pay
attention to how you emotionally and
emotionally respond to that to see if it
feels like if it could it be a fit or
not right what other experiments could
you run well what you could do after
you've done that or alongside it is try
to figure out if there is a way for you
to shadow someone say at an emergency
room and this is this is something I've
actually done and there's no harm in
figuring out how to ask how you might do
something like that even if you are
ultimately not granted permission right
so even in a case that is particularly
seemingly difficult like that there are
experiments you can run and the the
upshot of this is that you are going to
need to try a bunch of stuff right I was
not planning on ever writing a book ever
I was not planning on writing the 4-hour
workweek I had had very difficult
experience with writing my senior thesis
as an undergrad and I'd sworn to myself
I would never write anything longer than
an email ever again so if you had asked
me at age 25 or even 27 probably if I
wanted to write a book if I wanted to be
an author the answer would have been
absolutely not hell no but in the
process and I did this accidentally but
you can do it by design in the process
of teaching classes related to
entrepreneurship and getting a very
strong response from students who are
undergrads and masters students from
certain aspects of my talks I began to
think it could make sense to give a
separate guest lecture this is at
Princeton at the time focusing on
something that I struggled to label but
nonetheless ended up calling lifestyle
design as opposed to how to build a
fast-growing
bootstrapped business and and how to
engineer that to to function and it was
through that seemingly unrelated
practice and brainstorming that the
content for the 4-hour workweek before
the title ever existed came about and
then someone else suggested no in effect
just like added a snarky comment to a
feedback form at Princeton which is not
rare which was I don't understand why
you're teaching a class of 40 students
why don't you just write a book and be
done with it which I don't think was a
serious recommendation it was just a
dickish a dickish response from a
dickish kid who's been trained to think
that's awesome at Princeton but
nonetheless that's stuck in my head and
I took notes on possible chapter titles
headlines content etc so that I could
get to sleep because it gave me insomnia
and then only had conversations with
agents and so on after someone made
introductions without really asking me
if they could make them or not and then
the book was turned down by 27
publishers right so it's almost like
that entire path was something that I
turned away from multiple times and
nonetheless it has turned into one of
the greatest gifts I've ever received
certainly that experience paved the way
for everything including the podcast and
failures can also offer you tremendous
opportunities right after the 4-hour
chef which really completely burned me
out it's a very difficult book to put
together honest honest punched a suicide
deadline if I had not been burned out by
the 4-hour chef if I'd still had a lot
of gas in the tank I would have never
tested the podcast format as a sandbox
for intellectual exploration and having
the types of conversations I now have on
a weekly basis and share with the world
that never would have happened if I had
not run headfirst into a brick wall with
the 4-hour chef
so number one just in in review because
I want to make sure that try to
summarize this and then have a chance to
call some other folks number one if
you're having these feelings of being
unfocused or not sure what to do with
the rest of your life
that is normal and in fact the majority
of the world is having that type of
feeling at least a few times a year so
number one don't freak out because it's
normal and number two is do an
assessment you really need to understand
where you are and what your baseline is
before you can make any type of plans or
draw up possible experiments for finding
the things that you feel you lack that
would be the 80/20 principle at least as
one option that I think is particularly
effective and then the second is coming
up with experiments and identifying
different ways to stick your toe in the
water or different waters to gauge how
that feels and whether that provides you
with some degree of inner peace or
excitement and I do think that those are
two pretty good litmus tests for a lot
of the decisions you make might make in
life does it excite you and are you
excited to talk to other people about it
and Richard which are separate they
don't you don't have to check both of
those boxes and then you know how
excited are you or peaceful are you when
you wake up in the morning and how
easily do you go to sleep alright like
anything that can facilitate sort of
those four metrics I think generally
falls into the good decision category in
my experience but a you don't have to
figure it out for the rest your life and
I think it's highly likely that you will
at 27 particularly given the rate of
technological change and new industries
that will be created will in fact have
multiple careers throughout your life
and
you don't have to figure out which one
to stick with because I think that might
in fact be a losing strategy for most
people you want to develop skills and
relationships that transcend any one
narrow area of specialty unless you're
in a some type of like nano particle
physicist who's you know committed to
really specializing that's fine too but
from the from the sound of of where
you're describing I would say
experimentation experiment experiment
experiment does that help at all
yes Tim that was extremely helpful and
I've been taking notes here as I've
learned it's the right way to do things
and I appreciate your thorough answer it
never does disappoint my pleasure you
know I'm just trying to make make
something up that sounds believable so
I'm glad it if it can aid you in any way
that it that is genuinely though how
I've how I've approached things with
very rare deviation for the last say
certainly the last decade and I would
say even a little bit longer so I'm
gonna let you get back to your day but
thanks for lending an ear and thanks for
filling out the form hey thanks a lot
Tim and when our paths cross next I'll
ask you again about the cocktail but
until then thanks for the call and I
appreciate everything you have a good
day all right all right you two men bite
hello is this Menil am I getting that
pronunciation right you are and what an
honor it is for me well let's not speak
too soon I might flub the whole thing
but we'll we'll see how it goes how are
you this afternoon I am doing superb
talking to you so you know just do the
work meetings you know the 9 to 5 grind
the emphasis of your first book you know
there's there can be a time in a place
there can be a time in a place for it so
how can I try to be of assistance I
can't promise good answers but I will do
my best
well you know it's team not wine or
tequila this time so uh you know this
might not be as good but my question for
you today was a regarding relationships
and you know basically you you're very
methodical and everything that you do
you know you kind of plan ahead and you
always like try and anticipate any
downsides and plan for those yeah Giada
so that's kind of my mind so I have
learned a lot of that from you
I was wondering like how can I do that
in a relationship where my partner or my
girlfriend is and isn't really so prone
to that or kind of bottles up or you
know doesn't want to plan due to the
anxiety of it yeah I uh I I think we
have some we have some fertile ground to
explore here so I might rely on
follow-up questions from you to direct
this but I can tell you how I used to
think about it and now how I think about
it which is evolving and as we speak
but I realized in the last say five to
ten years that my ultimate nightmare
would be dating a long-term version of
myself so they're the sort of assumption
number one is that I am looking for a
compliment someone who is a compliment
and I have a fantastic girlfriend right
now we've been together for a pretty
decent stretch of time and she's proven
to be a fantastic compliment I can
explain what that means in a second to
me as it stands right now I'm not
looking for a duplicate and at the same
time I'm looking for someone with shared
values right how do they view truth how
do they define success if they define
success at all right so they should be
shared value could be
and I think it is on many levels how you
define certain terms that people tend to
strive for or strive to avoid and how
you answer certain key life questions
outside of that there's a lot of room
for flexibility and what I have found is
for me at least what is helpful when you
perceive say I could get myself in
trouble here both I can't blame it on
the booze and this applies to the last
probably last four or five relationships
I've had which have all been with
incredible women and brilliantly strong
women in different ways that I separate
in my mind what is emotional fragility
or lack of resilience from sensitivity
and I think this is a really important
distinction which I didn't by the way
draw for myself for many decades and I
think it did a lot of damage in other
words sensitivity to me is reflective of
to use one metaphor a precision
instrument right so if you have a scale
that gives you your weight but it's in
ten pound increments that is less
sensitive than a scale that gives you
pound by pound increments and a very
sensitive scale would give you down to
the gram and so on the question then is
how someone wields that sensitivity and
whether it is a help or a liability or
when it are asking the question when is
that sensitivity a help or liability so
you find I think that has
directly from me I have viewed any type
of feeling of feelings to be unhelpful
to be a primitive clouding of logical
analysis and for a long time therefore
my response to emotional responses in
myself was to stuff them down cut them
off
mute them turn down the volume and as a
result I made some really bad decisions
there were times when it was yeah oh no
I was just gonna say I know you said you
basically have started relying more on
your gut instincts rather than pro/con
list
yeah and you use both right so I think
that it's a it's a mistake to
exclusively rely on either but the there
is a lot to be said for the hundreds and
thousands and millions of years of
evolution that have given us rapid
processing ability that doesn't have to
run through a four-quadrant grid in the
analytical mind there's a lot to be said
for it right if a deal looks great but
you get the heebie-jeebies from person
you're doing the deal with I pay a lot
of attention to that the reason I bring
it up is that I think it is equally easy
to say date a in this case we're both
dating women
data woman or partner who is very very
sensitive and to mistake that for
weakness it's so one thing that I try to
do is to get a very clear understanding
of how sensitive their instrument is
mana for instance one of my
ex-girlfriends
I only realized after we'd been together
for several years that when she walked
down the street she was so emphatically
receptive that she could basically feel
the pain and emotions almost like a
contagion of people as she passed them
walking down the sidewalk like walking
down the sidewalk in New York City was
incredibly emotionally depleting for her
and I didn't know I didn't realize she
was that sensitive I didn't and that's
not a it's not a value judgment it is an
assessment of like her instrumentation
and that changed how I related to what
I'd previously perceived as like very
unreasonable and may be immature
responses to things does that make sense
so that's that's kind of 0.1 and I find
it also very I find it more productive
these days and I should say right off
the bat which I didn't that many people
have suggested like or asked me when are
you gonna write the for our relationship
and aside from us a terrible sounding
title the fact that I I don't think I
have right now a whole lot to contribute
to that conversation there are a million
in one books out there about
relationships some of them are very good
I think the five love languages is
actually an excellent book and it's been
recommended to me by by some of the most
impressive humans on the planet off the
romantic language that might be a
separate one the five love languages
maybe somebody should write that one too
the five love languages I do think for
particularly for very Spock admiring
left brainers and I know that the left
and right brain functions are not as
cleanly delineate it is this but just
for the sake of simplicity that book is
very helpful
and where's going to go next though is
that for for quite a long time my
response to perceived weakness was
frustration and it still is sometimes
the frustration was based on my
perception of whatever their reaction
was and I had no I had no visibility
into their internal process this goes by
the way for employees it goes for
everybody not just significant others
and what but I've certainly come to
practice a lot more is before getting
frustrated asking what they're
experiencing asking them to describe how
they're feeling recognizing that their
response exists whether you want it to
or not so you might as well have a bit
more resolution on what they're actually
experiencing and it can end up being
very very reasonable and not only that
but even if it is from your perspective
unreasonable simply recognizing that
their experience is valid and even
saying I can see how a B and C would be
very difficult I hear you like I could
see that and I have friends who
experience similar things or I've
experienced similar things often defuses
the situation without you having to
offer a solution at all or to go
critique the response so that's another
sort of consideration there is a this is
the type of thing that's probably gonna
get me in trouble but here goes so that
the 20% of you out there who just love
to kind of sport outrage on the Internet
you can use this one there is a there's
a book that I highly highly recommend
for everyone to read and I've
recommended it before for many many
different situations or to as education
and a toolkit for many many types of
challenges that can crop up there's a
book called don't shoot the dog which is
written by I believe it's Karen Pryor
and it's at its at its most basic a book
about positive reinforcement and it
happens to teach a lot of lessons
through discussion of sort of animal
conditioning right marine animals
dolphins and so on also looking at every
possible creature imaginable and I think
the back copy of the back cover of this
book says something like whether you
want the cat to get off of your kitchen
table or like your mother and a lot of
stop nagging you this book will give you
the tools you need something like that
and the title I think does not do
justice to the book but it's it's very
useful particularly when you how long
have you been dating your girlfriend
it'll be like two and a half years
getting up very close to three okay so
two and a half three years in both of
you probably have I think this is true
for most couples by this point certain
triggers for each other you have certain
sure you have habits that annoy the [ __ ]
out of her
maybe she bites her lip maybe she
doesn't I'm sure she has a few that
drive you nuts
and they're probably also exchanges
wherein you end up in a
self-perpetuating cycle of some type
right like and I'm not saying this is
trivial relationship but for instance
right like you perceive her as being
clingy or needy in some way so you push
away or shut down which makes her even
more fearful that you're withdrawing so
she doubles down on the clinginess and
the neediness then you double down on
the pushing away and it just it's right
right that type of dynamic it might
exist so in those types of dynamics it's
very useful to have as a reference point
it book like this that covers principles
of positive reinforcement right because
the negative reinforcement can work but
there are a lot of side effects does
that make sense so it's like for
instance yeah and and this book gives a
lot of examples negative reinforcement
can work yeah it's like if you want to
use a shock collar with a dog and I'm by
the way just for everybody out there
who's just like waiting to throw
pitchforks at my head not not comparing
women to dogs I'm comparing
humans to animals because we are animals
all right so just chill the [ __ ]
right and and I think a lot of our
problems day to day quite frankly is
thinking that we are uniquely special
like animals when for most intents and
purposes that's just not the case at all
like there's there's plenty of great
literature and science that we can
review to get a better understanding of
why we do some silly things and engage
in self-defeating behavior and thought
patterns which from an evolutionary
standpoint make a lot of sense so this
is part of that that education for me at
least and the benefit of it is one of
the benefits is that you're not reading
about evolutionary biology in a purely
theoretical or abstract way I mean
there's some great books by Dawkins and
others that can inform this conversation
what's nice about something like don't
shoot the dog is that it gives you tools
you can immediately practice in real
life so that's that's one I would
suggest that will give you an
alternative palette of options
mix in a lot of metaphors palette of
colors ie options that you can paint
with when you're you're in these
situations and give me another excuse a
specific example of a situation or a
response something that you wish were
different whether it's all going
preferably something that repeats right
something that you see repeatedly right
so I mean the big one obviously obvious
always a big thing in relationships
financials there is like well she's
gonna kill me if she hears this but
there is a little Robert Robert that's
okay Robert keep playing that I said
that's it's okay Robert don't worry
about it continue oh yes yes yes exactly
it's just like you know we have a little
bit of uh you know and we income
inequality right yeah I do make a little
bit more than her which is I'm sure you
know there's
always income despairity but uh I I've
always been very frugal my whole life
like in terms of you know see always
save a ton don't live beyond your means
or whatever and least time I tried and
talked financials it just I get shot
down there's no there's no discussion to
be had it's just well you have yours and
I have mine let's just figure it out and
for somebody I wanna you know and the
rest some rest of my life with it's it
becomes difficult especially when I've
been raised so financially conscious as
I am okay this is a good example and
because it's it's a it represents a
really common source of friction really
common I mean this is this is this is
not a rare conversation and it's not a
rare conversation where one or more
parties shut down so I I can only speak
to tools that have been helpful to me
I'll speak to a tool that's been helpful
to me and also a buffer and I'll explain
what I mean by that so the tool which
can become a bit rote and repetitive if
you overuse it is nonviolent
communication and there are many books
on the subject
there is a particular audiobook version
that neil strauss eight or nine times
near Times bestselling author
recommended to me I believe the first
name is from Marshall the author the
audiobook has I think a peace sign on
the cover and it's several hours long
in any case nonviolent communication you
could certainly read the Wikipedia entry
for the basics but in effect it is a it
is an approach to communication that
aims and I'm probably going to piss off
a bunch of nonviolent communication
black belts out there who are gonna say
that I got it all wrong but for the
purposes our conversation right now to
minimize the likelihood of provoking a
strong emotional response in the person
you're speaking with
and in yourself and the I'm gonna try to
recall this template right now there are
different ways to approach it but the
way it will generally start is along the
lines of you know when a B and C
happened or when you did a B and C and
the this first part is has to be
objective it cannot be debatable right
so it could be something like when we
agreed you know when we agreed to meet
at 3 o'clock and you turned up at 3:20
it's what it's what a video camera would
have recorded it makes me feel X because
I have a need for Y right it makes me
feel sad because I have a need to feel
that we're in this together and that
we're we're going to always strive to
keep commitments to each other and then
there's a specific ask which is like
would you be willing to and the the
would you be willing to could be
anything it could be would you be
willing to set aside a time to have a
conversation about this any time that's
convenient for you it's really important
to me because for instance in your case
I literally want to spend the rest of my
life with you and I this is important to
me because I was raised a B and C like
would you be willing for us to set aside
some time whenever is convenient for you
to put it in the calendar so we can
actually talk about this and it's a
template the goal being when I described
previously right so I would look into
nonviolent communication for these types
of conversations that have historically
produced the same response whether in
your partner or in yourself right and
then the buffer that I was mentioning is
and this took me it's so obvious and yet
it took me you know 41 42 I can't
remember how old I am right now
but whatever my age is right now I
should have figured this out earlier and
that is it's not just the message it's
the messenger and what I mean by that is
when
when you get into a pattern in my
experience where partner says a the
other partner shuts down or responds
with B and it's just
Groundhog Day that's what's what may be
needed and it's not they're not mutually
exclusive what might be required of both
is not the perfect wordsmithing
that is gonna be like your Luke
Skywalker in Star Wars like shooting
throws down the line in the Death Star
like it's not the perfect prose
paragraph that's going to just bestow
this miraculous epiphany upon your
girlfriend who's gonna pick oh my god
now I see hit write rather than hoping
to like craft the perfect Gettysburg
Address that's gonna like revolutionize
how she thinks about finances maybe she
just needs to hear exactly what you're
saying
through someone who is less threatening
or with whom she hasn't established that
pattern and I'm sure that again I'm not
a relationship counselor but in my
experience when I'm like I can't believe
she does X I usually have a very active
role in provoking that somehow right so
it's its price it's likely that the the
credit slash blame is shared by both
parties but in the last year or so I
have been and I'm like embarrassed to
admit this I don't know why what that's
about we can unpack that another time
but found a relationship coach to meet
with or speak with on a regular basis
and she will speak to me individually
she'll speak to my girlfriend
individually and then we'll have group
calls has enabled my girlfriend to say
things or convey things to me through
someone else who can also act as a
reality check for her end for me when I
have a concern or a criticism she's more
than willing to tell me that she thinks
it's unreasonable or that I'm
overreacting and as she's put it she's
she's not for I
one of us she's for the relationship and
having someone who is a regular part of
your fostering of the relationship as a
couple even when there is not a problem
right who is consistently there to
ensure that like the plants are watered
before they start dying right has been
incredibly incredibly helpful and can
defuse a lot of this stuff through a
myriad of of different factors now one
of which being you can say to this say
relationship coach or wherever you might
choose to work with therapists that
you'd really like to bring this up in a
safe space where the three of you can
talk about it
and where she can voice her concerns to
you may be separately may be together
and and having someone to facilitate
that is at least in my experience over
the last year extremely extremely
helpful it is also helpful if you or
anyone like me can get a bit overwhelmed
or feel overwhelmed when a partner comes
to me with emotional challenges I mean
at some point you'll have to develop the
ability I'm not saying you don't I will
have to develop the ability and I am to
kind of better just sit and witness the
experience of an emotional challenge
without having to like immediately jump
in and offer solutions within 30 seconds
be like okay right probably gonna let's
be solution-focused which which
surprised not always make things better
I'm getting better at that and it's it's
a it's a process of practicing and
training and so on for me because it
doesn't come very naturally to have
someone else that your partner can vent
to who is not you is really worth the
money and time in and of itself and who
you can vent to by the way so that you
don't blow up
over dinner or god knows what at your
part right and then say to yourself for
the next two weeks for [ __ ] sake why
did I do that
what a like 12-car pileup of emotional
trauma I have to now try to clean up
this so that's the buffer that that I
might I might suggest and it's
relatively new to me to have that
because I like to think that I don't
need things like that and have realized
that that's at least from my experience
so far very Pennywise and pound-foolish
particularly if it sounds like you're
very committed to being with your
girlfriend and want to be with her for a
very very very long time so those are
those are a few of my thoughts and I
don't know how helpful those are but
they've been they've been helpful
certainly to me thus far awesome no I
really appreciate my takeaways from all
that obviously the three books three
love languages nonviolent communication
and fired one five love languages oh
don't shoot the dog yeah they're about
nonviolent communication and don't shoot
the dog
I can't prayer right so that and then
the messengerís that was kind of another
one I was like off yeah not always about
the message replaying in my head thank
you again
I just wanted to you know say thank you
for everything that you do and for the
call today I hope you have a wonderful
rest of the day
and hopefully this makes it to the
podcast if not is it possible to send a
recording of it to me it's planned for
the podcast so yeah I'm sure I'm sure
this will end up on the podcast so don't
worry it'll be just you Robert me and
our yeah you know a couple couple a
couple million best friends good luck
and thank you again you're welcome
have a great day bye bye
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday and that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek calm I'll
spell that out and just drop in with
your email and you'll get the very next
one and if you sign up I hope you
enjoyed this episode is brought to you
by wordpress.com
I love worthless I have used it for so
many years it's my go-to platform for
blogging and creating websites I use
wordpress.com for everything every day
my site Tim that blog is built on it
the websites for my books building tools
of titans tribe of mentors it's all
enormous calm and the founder Matt
Mullenweg where my close friends has
appeared on this show many times
just search Matt Mullenweg tequila
fairness or quite an exciting time
whether you're looking to create a
personal blog business site of both you
can make a really big impact right out
of the box when you build on
wordpress.com and you'll be in good
company it's used by the New Yorker
jay-z Beyonce 538 TechCrunch Ted CNN and
time just to name a handful
and one of my friends at Google she'll
remain nameless kiss told him that
wordpress.com offers the best
out-of-the-box
SEO imaginable and quote it's one of the
many reasons that nearly 30 percent of
the Internet is run on worthless you do
not need experience or to hire some
that's perhaps the best part where press
comm guide you through the entire
experience they have hundreds of designs
the templates that you can use and it's
easy to get started there's no need to
worry about security upgrades hosting
any of that now for 24/7 support and
they're very very responsive you have
questions they go right back to you and
this allows you to create the highest
quality with the least amount of
headache and friction so if you're
building a website period but my friends
come to me and ask what I use what I
recommend they use the answer is
wordpress.com so check it out
you want to get started today learn more
with a 15% discount off any new plan go
to wordpress.com forward slash Tim
create your website and find the plan is
right for you so learn more take a look
wordpress.com 4/10 15% off a brand new
website check it out
this episode is brought to you by
peloton which I've been using for about
a year now peloton is a cutting-edge
indoor cycling bike that brings live
studio classes right into your home you
could also do on-demand which is what I
do it will come back to that so you
don't have to worry about fitting
classes into a busy schedule or making
it to a studio or gym with a hectic or
unpredictable commute I for instance
have a peloton bike right in my master
bedroom at home and it's one of the
first things I do many mornings I wake
up I meditate for a bit then I knock out
a short 20 minute ride in my undies hard
to do that at the gym take a shower and
I'm in higher gear for the rest of the
day it's really convenient and has
become something that I look forward to
so you have a lot of options for one if
you like you can ride live with
thousands of other riders across the
country on an interactive leaderboard to
keep you motivated
there are also up to 14 new classes
added every day with more than 8,000
classes on demand and you can pick based
on length 45 minutes to 20 minutes or
whatever music hip-hop rock and roll or
save low-impact versus high intensity or
interval you can pick the class
structure and style that works for you
and in my case I quite liked Matt
wilfers and I tend to do on-demand and
listened to a lot of and watch many of
the same classes over and over but I'm
kind of promiscuous and also enjoy
classes from a lot of the other
instructors they have peloton and
amazing roster of incredible instructors
in New York City with a whole range of
styles and personalities so you can find
what you're in the mood for you also get
real-time metrics that you can use to
track your performance over time and
that will help I would say catalyzed you
to beat your personal best now that all
sounds good right
gamification yadda yadda yadda I didn't
think that it would work for me or in
any way incentivize me but they really
100% hit the nail on the head I was very
very impressed with how motivating it
was and it worked tremendously to keep
me pushing which quite honestly takes a
fair amount I can get quite lazy
particularly with anything that edges on
endurance which is kind of more than
five reps of anything for me so check it
out discover this cutting-edge indoor
cycling bike that brings the studio
experience right to your home peloton is
offering the listeners of this podcast a
limited time offer
one peloton calm that's fo and e peloton
PE l oto and calm and enter the code Tim
all caps at checkout and get $100 off of
accessories with your policy on bike
purchase so get a great workout at home
anytime you want check it out go to one
peloton calm and use the code Tim to get
started
you
[Applause]